the bush name is synonymous with gop
politics in america producing two
presidents of the united states
as well as the former governor of
florida and now the next generation of
the political dynasty is set to make its
mark
as george p bush has announced his run
for attorney general
of the lone star state but the media is
wasting no time attacking his support
for former president trump
and the modern conservative movement
blasting the candidate and saying that
he is betraying his family
in an effort to appease trump george p
bush
candidate for texas attorney general
joins me now to respond
uh our our first conversation uh great
to have you here
uh george thank you very much for
joining me great to be with you
now obviously i'm i'm a big supporter of
president trump uh i heard from a lot of
people knowing that you would be on this
evening
uh to ask you how can you convince
even we appreciated your support for
president trump we watched that happen
when it did
when he was running for president people
hear the name bush and have a variety of
different
opinions and feelings uh emotionally and
politically because sometimes we can
agree to disagree
what do you say to the trump supporters
watching this program
uh that how that you're different that
you're not
let's say a trojan horse that you're not
saying what needs to be said
at the time which many politicians do in
order to curry favor
uh how do you explain yourself being a
bush
and a very the unique one in the midst
of today's political
environment well tammy thank you so much
for having me you know
it's the same response when i first ran
for office in 2014 and that is that
it's my name on the ballot i'm my own
man i'm going to be on the phone if i'm
elected as attorney general and take
that call late at night if a
border patrol official falls in the line
of duty or if
a law enforcement official also falls by
the way that's four
so far this year in the state of texas
and so
when i talk about my record whether it's
as land commissioner or my support of
trump
you know i just stick to the facts the
fact is that in 2016 i was one of the
first statewide elected officials to
come out and support him
i raised a million and a half in support
of republican candidates with him at the
top of the ticket
it was a high water mark for republican
party politics in the state of texas and
in 2020
i boldly declared that trump was the
only thing standing between our country
the american people and socialism
and lo and behold i've turned out to be
correct with
over 30 trillion in total spending 6
trillion in just next year's
annual budget so yeah when you look at
my policies
i'm all about america first trump is the
center of the republican party
i'm my own man i support him and we need
to carry on that legacy capture the
lightning that he brought to the
republican party
so that we can help all of our fellow
republicans down ballot so
through the holiday season this year
you're the son of jeb bush
the conversations must be fascinating uh
you you're
very strong very uh distinct in your
support for the president
we know that many members of your family
do not like him
is there been any pressure on you what
is though do you not have those
conversations
how do you handle that well i think
we're just like any american family
and and that we have our differences of
opinion whether it's with respect to
president trump whether
it's respect to hot button issues of the
day but i just have my own vision my own
plan my own track record
here in texas um i think i've won over a
few souls just because of the first
150 days or so of the biden and harris
presidency and white house
administration i think with more time
and more policies that come from dc
probably went over a few more hearts and
souls
well hopefully maybe some of those
people would have the last name of bush
because we need some more of your family
to understand the power of president
trump
and what can happen for the american
people in this process i mean i think
that's what we're looking for
so this election is uh 2022 for attorney
general running against
uh the current attorney general paxton
uh you feel comfortable doing that
you got support you think you have the
support for that i do
i think texans deserve to have a choice
you know in 1976 ronald reagan ran
against an incumbent president because
he felt that in the wake of a terrible
political scandal in our own party that
conservatives should have a choice
and i believe that here in texas
republicans should have that choice
indeed
all righty well uh congratulations thank
you very much i'm sure i'll see you
again
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else